so my job here is really not to try and
make about men and women is to make you
understand that actually we need to
start changing the narrative we want to
make it about men and women because
they're both messed up on either side
because then women look bad no because
it's about everybody together women have
their traumas men have their traumas I'm
not here to fight against men and women
that's small I understand what you're
saying I understand what you're saying
but the idea the idea the idea that this
one percent of men have created this
terrible Society yeah I talk about that
I talk about the Matrix I talk about
these things but it's always been this
way it's always been a small Elite group
of men who are in charge of the world
and unfortunately now we're fighting
battles in different ways the the days
of old a man proved his worth by going
to war basically every man at any point
in his life was going to end up going to
war and he came back Victorious he came
back with honor he got himself a wife
that's that's how it worked right now
men don't have to go to war as much
depending on where you live in the world
and it's slightly different and we fight
our Wars in other ways